I want to announce that the lecture from
last Thursday failed to have an audio
recording so we could not put it up
online so those people who who missed it
will have no way to recover it and so
that will be the midterm exam right a
commentary on last Thursday's lecture
and we will see how those people who
actually come to class
how are rewarded in the muffuletta
cording this time and I am you know the
midterm I I mentioned is still in my
head
hopefully I will assign it before class
on Thursday but I've been thinking about
it I've come up with a whole bunch of
questions that I have one by one
discarded as being you know either
too hard or too easy or too much
or you know but I'll come up
with something don't worry there will be
a midterm if that was a concern anyone
had the chapter we have this week is
land empires in the age of imperialism
it strikes me that the authors who hit
on this is a title for a chapter really
we're desperate
they had no particular reason for
covering these topics I wonder what was
going through their heads when they
decided that this would be a suitable
topic for a chapter my recollection of
it is that we have some sort of concept
that we were going to be covering in the
subsequent two chapters Seabourn empires
particularly the British and imperialism
in the later part of the 19th century
and that we should give a nod to land
empires and yet why in the world would
we do that simply to cover territory
well yes to some degree but picking 1870
as a point of terminus enabled us to
avoid issues related to late imperialism
in the late 19th century but it has no
particular value and yet the stories
that are told in the chapter make a
certain kind of sense the when you look
at the non-european independent states
the ones that do not become completely
dominated by imperialism in the course
of 19th century you find that there is a
revolution in Turkey in 1908 there's a
revolution in China in 1911 is a
revolution in Iran in 1906 there's a
revolution in Russia in 1905 I'm
counting here Russia as a land Empire in
this sense because that's how it's
covered in the chapter
and so it might have made sense to go up
to the first first decade of the 20th
century and say isn't the long-term
takeaway of this of this 19th century
discussion of these empires isn't it the
fact that they all run into revolutions
and the revolutions are invariably very
messy so that the Chinese revolution
brings the Ching dynasty to an end but
it does not replace it with a coherent
government the Ottoman Empire goes
through a revolution if that does not
produce a very effective government
although it's very enthusiastic and
nationalistic one the constitutional
revolution in Iran does not produce a
terribly happy result and of course the
Russian Revolution of 1905 is simply a
entering into a waiting period until the
big revolution comes in 1918 in the
context of world war one and yet there
does seem to be this odd convergence
that you have revolutions at the at the
same time so if I were rewriting this
chapter I might be persuaded by by these
thoughts to extend the time frame of the
chapter and say that let us deal with
ends of empires now what what is
conducive toward the the end of a of a
dynastic regime and at the end of the
19th century instead of stopping around
but there's another perspective that we
do fulfill without really making it
absolutely clear what we're doing in
this chapter and that would be a
competing perspective that has to do
with the notion of the modern that you
look at this period of the early
nineteenth century as the beginnings of
the extension of modern things outside
of the European sphere but that of
course is the problem of what is
slaughtered as a specialist on the
Middle East and indeed as in that
capacity giving a course from time to
time on modern Middle Eastern history
I've spent a lot of time pondering this
question of why in the world we call
Middle Eastern history at any time
modern and what the modernity eilat
consists of prior to the end of World
War two there were no books written or
articles the best of my knowledge that
actually used the term modern Middle
East because the Middle East really had
not taken shape that was over post-world
War one phenomenon with the dissolution
of the Ottoman Empire but you did have
books that began to be written using the
word modern and here I'm specifically
talking about Middle East in nineteen
thirty one man named Dodd well wrote a
book called the founder of the father of
modern of the founder of modern Egypt
about Muhammad Ali who ruled and Lee ah
you know down to 1839 or so 1841 in the
early 19th century there was a book
written by Brigadier Stephen long Greg I
don't remember Lee yours published
called four centuries of modern Iraq
then there was a
book that came out in 1960 that probably
was the most the single book that shaped
the study the modern Middle East more
than any other book and that was by
Bernard Lewis was entitled the emergence
of modern querque now I remember when
the book came out I was an undergraduate
studying Middle East and it was kind of
a bombshell book now you had a book that
actually told you what it was that
underlay the modern Middle East and you
can understand very clearly what it what
its message was on almost exactly the
same time there was another book that
came out that covered exactly the same
subject matter it was called the
development of secularism in Turkey and
it was written by a Turkish scour and
people pay very little attention to it
oh it was the the perception of the
modern was seemed to be something that
was peculiarly adapted to the Western
scholarly vision modern in these books
basically means European it is it is a
approach to history that takes European
of European ism or adopt the adoption of
European you know ideas techniques so
forth as being the primary story
that needs to be told because that is
the story that introduces what is modern
in this story you have Muhammad Ali in
Egypt coming in in the aftermath of the
French withdrawal after Napoleon's
invasion of 1798 and building up a very
powerful Egyptian state that had very
strong European influences in the
construction of the military so that
Muhammad Ali created schools for
training military officers in
western-style military techniques and he
began a program of sending selected
young officers to France in particular
to study there and come back and be
be prepared to teach in these schools or
to you know advanced Western learning in
Egypt in some other respect he
introduced a printing press and start
printing a government Gazette that was
analogous to what you would have in
certain European countries and he
introduced an economic system that would
pay for all of this which was basically
a monopsonist system by which the the
egyptian government became the only
buyer of things you could grow wheat but
you could but you had to sell it to the
government and wheat was the main the
main product of Egypt at that time and
so the government would would set the
price for purchasing wheat would
purchase the wheat and then it would
sell it and a greatly inflated price on
the international market which was
starved for wheat because of the
Napoleonic Wars that had not only
reduced grain production in Europe but
had limited imports into Europe in the
the Continental System that the British
used to try to curtail you know the
French war effort so Muhammad Ali was
this is he set up a series of monopolies
or we call the monopolies or absolutely
monopsony so as I said in which the
state becomes the buyer of the
agricultural products of Egypt it sells
them at a higher price uses the proceeds
to set up a larger military to build
factories to produce military goods
uniforms weapons etc sets up schools to
train the military in western techniques
and ultimately goes conquering and so
Egypt conquers Syria and eventually goes
beyond and appears to be on the verge of
conquering the Ottoman Empire I would
say of taking Istanbul until the
Europeans intervene and bring this to an
end at the end of the 1830s the
Egyptians are forced to go back to Egypt
the monopsony Tsar dissolved there's a
limit placed on the size of the Egyptian
army and the whole Muhammad Ali episode
comes to an end although his family
continues to rule in Egypt down until
1952 okay that was that was modern Egypt
and modern Egypt or that was the
beginning of modern age of foundational
modern age of modern age of being
defined in this sense as the adoption of
specific European practices including
European teachers to come in and teach
at the at the new schools the schools
were military schools but they covered
subjects that were fairly broad for
example you have a music school
established in Egypt then later one in
Istanbul so that people will learn
presumably a military music you have
music in Muslim armies going back
hundreds of years before this if you
ever listened to the Turkish March by
Mozart or certain passages in abduction
from the seraglio you'll hear how Mozart
imitates the sound of an ottoman army no
bad enough that I'm not not that I don't
know and it kind of blaring and not very
sophisticated whereas now they wanted to
have music that would sound
sound European exactly qui is never
precisely explained although there is
this an interesting anecdote by a
Hungarian
traveler who Hungarian Jew converted to
Catholicism and then traveled through
the Middle East pretending that he was a
Sufi Sheikh and so he would go to places
dressed up those local holy man and
deceived the locals this is something
that the Europeans just really got off
on let's go and deceive locals into
thinking that we're holding them and at
one point he found himself in
Afghanistan and a small contingent of
British soldiers marched by because
Britain was competing with Russia to
have influence in Afghanistan and after
they went by a man came up and tapped
him on the shoulder and said that the
Emir wanted to see him so he went off to
see the ruler the governor of city of
Herat and the governor said you're a
European attending to be a Sufi Sheikh
and traveling through my domains aren't
you
and Arminius Bambury the travelers him
you know yes I am now you you got me
what tipped you off and he said it was
reported that you tapped your foot when
the British went by and no Muslim would
happens foot - - very music so it may be
that the answer to the music coming into
Ottoman and Egyptian military affairs
has something to do with arranging large
military movements in which you use
drums - marching in step in order to
perform military maneuvers
I really don't know I've never found a
history strictly of music school but it
was one of those things that that fit
the notion of a of a European innovation
now and that's fine that this it's all
all sounds good Mohammed Ali was a
powerful figure he had a powerful army
he did some conquering he ultimately
lost but his but he installed his family
empower they later became declared kings
of Egypt after World War one but there's
a question is whether this is the most
important thing happening in Egypt at
this time and or is this is this a
selectivity that is bent toward a
presumed importance of Europeanization
over anything else not as mentioned two
things that happened in Egypt at this
time that might point in a different
direction
one of them was
and both of them have to do with
religion first of them has to do with
the with the the donations that people
made as trusts for pi pious purposes or
maintenance of their family the word is
a walk plural is a pop and Turkish
Ottoman form the buck off' and epitaph
these trusts took up an enormous amount
of the wealth the productive wealth of
Middle Eastern countries a study for
example in the large Syrian city of
Aleppo around 1800 showed for example
that every single shop in the covered
bazaar in Aleppo was owned by a walk
there was no longer any private
ownership because people who had once
owned these shops had
donated the shops in perpetuity as a
trust so that the income from the shops
how to say the rents received by the
trustee of the walk would be devoted to
the purposes that were designated by the
by the Miwako by the person who
established the trust and this was
supposed to be in perpetuity so that
since the the principle of a walk came
from income-producing property or an
income-producing entity it meant that
you were taking real estate particularly
urban real estate but also rural real
estate you're taking out of circulation
and you were shifting up to a to a
monetary regime where it could never be
sold you know forever and gradually more
and more property was coming under walk
which of course meant a stronger and
stronger limitation on what revenues the
government could collect because this
land was no longer paying taxes as
income was being paid for for these
benevolent purposes the nature of the
benevolence would vary it's been argued
I think pretty soundly that most public
services and social services that we
think of today as being the purview of
government in its let's say in its non
libertarian mode that most of those
services and functions were being
fulfilled by by the alcohol so that
if you had a hospital the hospital would
be supported by by a walk if you have a
school be supported by a walk and you
had a fountain for people to have clean
drinking water be supported this this
analysis is a little bit illusory
because careful studies of al-kahf that
have been done recently show that you
have a great variability from one city
to another as to the purposes for which
al-kahf were were used in one city and
Palestine for example 90% of the al-kahf
were used for the support of the
descendants of the donor so that you
would have a the the rents would be
collected and then paid out to all of
the living descendants of the donor with
there being some sort of other pious
purpose beyond that but only after the
family died out in another city of the
same size at the same time in Lebanon
90% of the alcohol were used for for
public benefits not for for private
maintenance of families so we it's a
somewhat murky subject that hasn't been
thoroughly studied yet but certainly it
was a very important part of the of the
of the economy and the notion of it
really continues down to the present day
to some extent so that one of the
biggest universities in Turkey is
Bilkent University which is not very old
established 120 years ago something like
that but it is supported by 40
corporations all of whose profits go to
go to the university but the university
is prohibited from buying any goods for
many of the corporations essentially
this is
a huge walk where the corporations are
obligated some of them are very large
corporations obligated to transfer all
of their profits to the you know to the
university so bill candidate university
being so very becomes a very large and
very wealthy university not because
there is one philanthropist there's one
entrepreneur who puts them all together
but it isn't like Stanford or something
where you have one one person who says
this will be my legacy but rather it's
set up as a as a public benefit
supported by this alright why am I
talking about the alcohol because
Muhammad Ali abolish them he made the
argument or his his thinkers made the
argument that during the three-year
period of the French occupation of Egypt
the land of Egypt had passed out of the
realm of Islam the dar al-islam and to
become part of the realm of war the
darle harbor and that by by ceasing to
be part of the land of islam those
things that were predicated on Islamic
law namely the al-kahf had all had all
been dissolved just it's a fact Oh once
the French took over the walks not the
French did nothing to the alcohol though
they did abolish them but haben Ali said
they are they it so back to elapsed
because this ceased to be Muslim land
and therefore this is unoccupied
property and they will until he seized
it for the government which meant that
he took over those things that were paid
for them by the alcohol such as the
upkeep of lost schools payment of
salaries of religious officials and so
forth but now he had control of the
income and he could pay whatever he
wanted
for these services or functions or he
could minimize them and keep as much of
the revenue as he wished for his own
purposes so this was along with his
monopsonist policies was a way of
funneling revenue into the government so
that he could do these these other
things but of course it had a profoundly
destabilizing effect upon the religious
community in Egypt because here you had
individuals and families that had
oriented themselves around public
benefits and and it it disappeared it
later on reappears so you have down to
say down to recent decades you have
private mosques being created in Egypt
again I mean it's once it goes back into
the Islamic realm than the the walk once
again comes into being but but it was an
example of
the government
eradicating one of the fundamental
building blocks of religious society in
Egypt the second thing that he did that
doesn't get talked about what went along
similar lines ever since 1300 or so
Muslim society had been increasingly
dominated by Sufi Brotherhood's and Sufi
Brotherhood's spread from Morocco to
Indonesia they were highly diverse and
they did not recognize national
boundaries so that you could have a Sufi
Brotherhood in Morocco that would be
that would think of itself as being a
chapter of a Sufi Brotherhood that had
other chapters in in Egypt or
Afghanistan or India or Indonesia prior
to 1300 Islam was never really organized
in a spatial sense you didn't have many
organizations the Sufi Brotherhood's
were very specifically and explicitly
membership organizations and as such
even though they were not formally
competitive they were situationally
competitive because you had thousands of
these Brotherhood's in 1800 the
beginning of 19th century and they were
looking for adherence and if you became
an adherent it meant that you were going
to follow the rule established by the
know the shape of that Brotherhood and
that rule would would compel you to do
certain things in a ritual manner or to
live in a certain way in some cases will
compel you to give money to the to the
Sheikh enormous amount of variety in
this
most of the Senegalese taxi drivers in
New York belong to a Sufi Brotherhood in
which they funnel money to the shape of
the of the Brotherhood and that's watch
taxi drivers as people who sell you know
knockoff Rolex watches on no Fifth
Avenue so on they belong to the movie
idea Brotherhood when they come over
here on a tourist visa live in sort of a
group home with other movies for three
months until their tourist visa expires
and they're peddlers and then they go
back to Senegal and then they're
replaced by others the more ideas one of
the two great Sufi Brotherhood's of
Senegal so these were not trivial they
were profoundly important for the
society and in the number of places they
are the cutting edge of opposition to
imperialism this takes place in Somalia
takes place in Afghanistan all right now
Algeria in Morocco in Sudan and you
think well that's sort of a quaint 19th
century thing but a number of the
Mujahideen groups who fought against
Russia or the Soviet Union in
Afghanistan in the 1980s were based on
Sufi Brotherhood's because they truly do
engage Muslims in their activities at a
very profound level so at Muhammad Ali
tried to do was to regulate them and he
said well we'll divide Egypt into
districts and in this district
Brotherhood a kin can seek adherence but
it cannot seek adherence in district B
because that will be the territory of
another Brotherhood this effort to to
control the Brotherhood's is parallel to
the effort to
probably the al-kahf and somewhat later
in the century we'll see a parallel
effort to to control the the artisan
guilds and what this really amounted and
even beyond that to reorganize the
spatial life of people in these
countries Muslim countries when it
amounted to was a century long or a
century and a half long process of D
institutionalizing the religious aspects
of society that had been dominant for
pretty much ever since the the end of
the Mongol phase of Middle Eastern
history and 1335
this was something that the Europeans
sort of knew vaguely they didn't follow
it the French may have followed it more
because after they conquered Algeria in
1840 they they had some scholars who
were assigned to make a basically an
encyclopedia of all the Sufi
Brotherhood's but after they had
defeated their main opponent they who
had a Sufi background they were able to
proceed without formally just
establishing the Brotherhood's except
most of the Algerian Brotherhood's
disappear in the course of 19th century
so from one point of view you can say
this is a period of Europeanisation from
another point of view you can say this
is a this is a period where the
Islamization occurs the populations
remain Muslim but the institutional
structure of the of the society to the
degree that that structure is predicated
on Islamic practices is increasingly
eroded by the government the Ottoman
Empire follows in the same the same path
starting in 1829 and there the the
process is called
the Tanzimat or the reorganization
Bernhard Lewis in his book on the
emergence of modern Turkey really says
this is what we should be studying is
the Tanzimat because under the Tanzimat
you had the adoption of European
military practices you had the
establishment of military schools you
had instructors brought in from Europe
to teach in the schools
you had Ottoman officers who were sent
to Europe to learn European ways and it
going farther than whatever happened in
Egypt you had not in 1829 when the
Tanzimat begins but in 1836 after 1821
in 1836 and 1839 1856 that you gradually
have a installation of European views at
an ideological level so that the
beginning of the Tanzimat portrays the
actions of the Sultan as being within
the framework and the the leeway given
to Sultan's within Islam by the time you
get to 1856 declarations of equality of
all religions and so forth that appear
to be very European in inspiration
become the hallmark of the tongs Ahmad
the Ottoman government establishes
secular schools that are designed to
feed into the military schools the War
College in Istanbul so you have military
high schools in different parts of the
Empire you have a increasing involvement
of the legal system with European law
codes taking the form of adopting almost
without change aspects of European
codified law that particularly from
Belgium that will cover certain areas of
litigation so you'll adopt a commercial
code a criminal code so forth until
Islamic law becomes increasingly
relegated to a minor role concentrating
primarily on personal status and family
law and inheritance and most other areas
of law are codified in European form the
the result of this is that the number of
jobs available for religiously trained
people diminishes because you have in
the legal system you now need people who
are trained in Western concepts of law
and gradually the number of positions in
the educational system diminishes and by
the late part of the century you're
having the al-kahf the F calf taken
under government control and the revenue
is distributed by the government rather
than by the individual trustees who had
always been the administrators of the of
the al-kahf system so the Ottoman
government moves in the same direction
as the as the Egyptian government they
do not they're a little hesitant to move
against the Sufi Brotherhood's that
doesn't take place until until after
World War one when the Sufi
Brotherhood's are formally abolished but
the Brotherhood that was most strongly
associated with the Janissary Corps
which was seen as a military unit of
profound corruption and waste that that
Brotherhood is abolished
that's the Bektashi Brotherhood now
abolishing it doesn't mean it disappears
we always say it was abolished and so
there are no more Bektashi she's in fact
the Bektashi czar alive and well in
Albania where they survived not only
from the Ottoman period but the
communist regime you still have Bektashi
she's around
similarly efforts to abolish the Sufi
Brotherhood's in the 1920s really failed
failed to do so but the point was that
the the government was moving against
those institutional forms that were most
strongly related to the to having Islam
be at the foundation of the society most
of these aspects of the Tanzimat era are
not discussed by Vernon Lewis or the
other people who've written on Turkey in
this period there more discuss now than
they were in say in the 1960s because
that I think the scholars saw it as
being sort of beside the point the point
was that the good things from Europe
like no modern weapons conscription good
artillery you know the good things from
Europe were coming in including law and
ultimately constitutionalism
and that's the story it's a story of the
the good European stuff entering into
the society and if that had a
counterpart of the of the institutional
structure of the of the society based on
Islam with we're either withering away
or being destroyed you know
in a very purposeful fashion that wasn't
that that was okay that was collateral
damage
you know nobody wanted to slum around
anyway if they were Europeans and so it
didn't become a subject of discussion no
I'd argue that this is that this was a
big mistake and that the Europeanisation
to the degree that it was supposed to
create powerful armies constitutional
government elections liberty equality
fraternity etc it really didn't do it
you know you come down to the 20th
century and you say did the Islamic
empires of the early 19th century
European eyes to the extent that they
became as powerful as the European
powers and as well accepted and as
committed to the to the modern
institutional forms of government inside
in Europe and the answer is clearly no
they did not become sufficiently
powerful militarily to vote to win a war
against against a European power they
did not develop constitutions that were
very effective they were so fragile
they're easily taken over by
dictatorships in the 20th century and so
here you have a story that we take to be
the main story and it's a story that
sort of withers away the outcome you
know you have all this effort that we're
told about that's put into creating a
new way of doing things in a European
fashion that does not produce a European
style
Society or European style institutions
it produces sort of tepid imitations of
them that are pretty much easily
easily overcome on the other hand the
concurrent efforts to to deus lamas eyes
the lands and to undermine or eradicate
the institutions of religious
inspiration that had been the primary
structuring elements with society for
several hundred years that was
remarkably successful not done not
totally successful but it by and large
worked so that the Sufi Brotherhood's
they don't disappear but they become
vastly diminished the religious
educational system does not disappear
but it becomes vastly diminished Islamic
law does not disappear but it is
curtailed to a very very extensive
degree by the new law codes the guild
system that had been the primary
structure of buying and selling and
producing goods for let's say from the
14th century onward the guild system
disappears almost everywhere and then
you had a urban renewal and the urban
renewal which became an important aspect
of of change particularly in Cairo and
Istanbul the sort of capital cities the
urban renewal would take the form of
building long straight streets that
carriages could go on without paying a
whole lot of attention to what else was
there these visions of having a Parisian
like Haussmann eyes capital we're very
intoxicating for
for rulers and city planners but they
didn't take into account the way the
population actually actually lived and
in some places many places you can see
the ways in which the urban changing the
urban fabric destroys the underlying
structure of the society if you compare
let us say the French did a little
differently in North Africa they would
have a good old city the wall around it
and all of the attributes of a
traditional Islamic city and then they
would build a parallel city outside the
walls so you had fans in Morocco and
then you had Fez Judy knew Fez outside
the walls that would be the modern city
and the result is that in North Africa
you still have urban structures that
that go back to the you know the period
from before the French invasion in 1840
'im in Algeria because they build a
parallel city instead of destroying the
old one in other places however the idea
was that you eradicate the old in the
city that I know best provincial city in
Iran called Nisha poor
you could see very clearly the it
happens later in Iran for reasons I'll
talk about another point but there when
the urban changes came the Shah of Iran
was entranced by the idea of traffic
circles or roundabouts and so here you
would take a almost every Iranian city
of any size had two broad boulevards or
Broad streets cup city now here's the
wall the city you've got two streets
very commonly they'll simply be called
Sima 330 meters streets because they're
very wide and then when you get outside
the wall
to a traffic circle where traffic circle
here but in these are poor this ended of
the railroad station but up here it
simply ended in dirt the streets weren't
designed to go anyplace they were paved
in here in town but they were dirt
gravel as soon as you got past the
traffic circle because they weren't
conceived of in terms of the circulation
of traffic they've conceived of in terms
of a modern a project that seemed to
have a European inspiration so what
would happen is that the government
buildings in the banks the new important
structures rebuilt appear in the in the
center where you know State Street
crossed Main Street but if you looked at
the old Bazaar the covered Bazaar ran
down that way and it was cut in half by
the new Boulevard and gradually it
disappeared and this would happen in
place after place after place this this
deliberate
of the structure of residents and the
distribution of business and so forth
it was not simply a European obsession
but it was a conscious effort to shift
the the governance of variety into the
hands of the government and out of the
traditional forms that would be
associated say with the guilds saying a
bazaar you would have the say that the
the coppersmiths would be here and the
Rope people would be here and the shoe
sellers the cobblers would be up here
each guild had a section in the in the
covered bazaar but now you would have
modern shoe stores and you know utility
indoors along these main streets the the
effort to undermine the existing society
is is somewhat obscure because when we
look at the at the adoption of law codes
and schools and military reforms and
ultimately things like constitutions and
elections we think of it as being this
is conscious Europeanization that we can
identify as Europeanization but these
other things that have to do with with
undermining the system of trusts
undermining the Sufi Brotherhood's
undermining the guild undermining the
the employment potential for people
trained in religious schools and finally
in undermining the built structure of
the community these things are not
manifestly European izing
Europeans were happy to see them happen
but they didn't really the Europeans I
don't think knew enough about the
society to have thought of these things
these were more or less the local ideas
rather than ones that came in from
Europe and yet these probably had more
to in my view present
I shouldn't say probably because well
people they won't disagree with me but
in my view these have more to do with
the structuring of something like a
modern a modern state in society then do
the superficial and indifferently
effective import of specific European
techniques and institutions so if you
look at it from this perspective then
the story becomes not modernization in
the sense of adopting what is European
but rather some kind of internal concept
of quite quite unexpressed in literary
terms some internal concept of changing
the society in a fashion that will
benefit the ruling establishment
why would they do that
if you look at the broad political
structure of Islamic society you find
that for particularly the period after
1300 that there is a uneasy relationship
between religion and the state the the
basic theory of Islamic law maintains
that anarchy is is the worst thing that
can occur an anarchy by their definition
is sort of that they're talking about
say Lebanon during the Civil War from
you know 1975 to 1990 where it's kind of
a war of many factions against each
other and no one having a chance to win
all the theorists were opposed to
anarchy and they they declared that the
state was necessary and they even went
so far particularly in the context of
the Mongols but later as well in the
context of imperialist rule they went so
far as to say that the state should not
be resisted or rebelled against so long
as it maintains Islamic law or some
vestiges of Islamic law or even one
aspect of Islamic law if the state is
recognizing this long then it should not
be it should not be opposed why was it
slack law the center because in theory
the tenant there was a union unanimous
agreement kind of a Hobbesian view that
the state moves toward tyranny by its
own nature this is the nature of
monarchy or of really of any state that
if they are not checked the people who
control the mate will will tend to
become tyrants this is very with
European political thought and European
political FOSDEM evolves notions that
the way you check the move toward
tyranny is by having popular
institutions like Parliament's you know
taxation that cannot be levied without
permission of Parliament so forth and so
on in this these regimes are
accomplished through revolution or
through the sorts of pressures and
threats of revolution and so you get the
idea in the West that between anarchy
and tyranny what keeps government in
line is the Volks popular even voice of
the people expressed in some fashion or
other but particularly in relation to -
money - you know if you can starve the
beast to use the current phrase take
away the money from the government you
will reduce the tyranny of the
government and we wring a great deal
about that these days this is the
tradition in Western political thought
now in the Islamic world the idea was
that what prevents
the state from becoming tyrannical is
Islamic law and that the keyword is the
the key aspect of this is not control of
money but rather the control of justice
so the when you have movements in Europe
they tend to focus on the word freedom
and in the 19th century at least 18th
century before that movements would tend
to focus on the word justice this is
what everybody aspired to justice was
thought of as being what was offered to
society by Islamic law so the the states
had Islamic law courts the law courts
did not have penal jurisdiction in other
words if you had a conviction the the
condemned person whether it was to
prison or death or whatever was turned
over to the civil arm of the government
for the execution of sentence the judges
themselves did not have an executioner
at their bidding nevertheless the judges
had a very large population of advisers
of people who were specialists on the
law who would advise them as to what was
just in a particular situation or they
would advise litigants so a litigant
would you did not have any lawyers in
the court but a litigant could go to a
jurist counseled and ask him for a for
an opinion that would support his side
in a case
this opinion was called a fewa the
person who giving was giving it either
have the office of or was performing in
the function of a Mufti meaning one who
gives a fatwa
all right each litigant could bring in
as many veterans as they wanted and if
the judge was uncertain about how to
understand the law the judge could he
had his own juris consult and the fact
was were basically like like legal
matter of fact the Sharia inspiration in
those in those centuries was closer to
English common law than anything else
because it was heavily based on
precedent and the scholar was the person
like the modern lawyer who had the
ability to go into the established
literature find the precedents bring
them to bear on the case at hand this
legal apparatus was supported in part by
the government financing of religious
schools but in almost every community
you had many of these jurists who are
locally educated and who are part of
important families employees of the
government
they were completely in the community
like professors are today people you
could go to and expect a good fair
appraisal of a situation and we
certainly know that people would shop
around for fetch was say you know you
you don't like my opinion well I'll go
to someone else you know better opinion
from him because the Fed was never
minded it's become binding now in Saudi
Arabia but normally a feta is not
binding it is simply an opinion so the
theory was that the ruler who is simply
another Muslim as much bound by Islamic
law as any subject in his realm that the
room could be challenged by
were unjust wrong and in extreme
instances say that it was warranted to
to overthrow him we've rarely happened
but did occasionally happen because the
legal system even though it consisted of
state appointees who were the judges and
in some cases the Muftis it depended
upon the notion that the Islamic law
evolves independently of government
through the through the collectivity of
the scholars and the schools that the
scholars attend which our schools are
financed by the al-kahf which are funds
given to the support of the schools by
private Muslim citizens in other words
the whole apparatus of law is in
government but is staffed by a mass of
people who are only partially within the
government when it came to sanctioning
the ruler
it didn't happen very often in you one
comparison you might make is with the
Confucian system very Confucian sage or
scholar who was working in the ministry
under an emperor Confucian philosophy
maintained that if he came if he
concluded that the emperor was doing
something that was wrong that was
criminal or you know vice ridden or
something like that it was a corruption
it was the duty of the Confucian
gentleman to remonstrate to go to the
Emperor and say what you are doing is
wrong but that did not mean that he
could call on people to overthrow the
Emperor what he was supposed to do was
to remonstrate and if the Emperor did
not change his practice he was supposed
to resign and we have many examples of
this
happening in Confucian society but
because you still but there the the
credentialing of her religious scholars
was much more a government project than
it was in the Islamic world because they
had an exam system so what you had was
the idea that Islamic law would be just
studies that have been done in recent
decades working at the detailed level of
how courts operated indicate that by and
large the Muslim courts were seen to be
just by the population so that when you
had Muslims in lawsuits with non-muslims
there was no presumption in favor of the
Muslim the non-muslim would win
proportionately as much as the Muslim or
when you had a lawsuit between a
government official and an ordinary
citizen there is no presumption that the
government official was right you would
have as many victories for one side for
the other so as far as we can tell
people thought that their legal system
was just and that the legal system was
where tyranny would be prevented doesn't
mean that the Sultan couldn't cut the
head off of his favorite wife and you
know throw the body and the Bosphorus
but if he did so it did not undermine
the legal system for example if if
nothing because example if you had an
American president who got a blowjob
from assistant in in a closet off of his
office would that undermine our legal
system no it would disgrace the
president or in some people's eyes maybe
you know make him seem like a good
fellow but but it wouldn't affect the
whole system so what we've done very
often in looking at oriental despotism
is to focus on the
the atrocities performed by rulers
without recognizing that most people
thought they were living in a pretty
just society and you know if you're
going to play with rulers you deserve
what you get anyway but okay the the
people who are ruling in the 19th
century recognized that there is this
long tradition that would curtail a move
toward tyranny because people would have
an atavistic sense that religion should
prevent tyranny what happened in the
early 19th century I'm convinced is that
the experience of the French Revolution
and Napoleon and perhaps you could throw
in some other exemplars here convinced
people that it was possible to be
absolutely tyrannical that you could
actually control religion because that's
what Napoleon did this whole business of
have it reaching a concordant with the
Pope reaching an agreement with the Jews
making everyone a co-equal citizen and
removing religion from the from the core
enterprise of the state in Europe this
certain ways but in the in the Islamic
world it was sort of a paradise if we
could just get rid of all of these
religious scholars think what we could
do and that is what Muhammad Ali did
that is what the Ottoman Sultan stood in
Tom ZMOT they I think they took they saw
Europe as a nearby example of
the possibility of bringing it under
control and they so they thought what
are the main pillars of a religious
society the Sufi Brotherhood's I'll call
the legal system educational system the
Guild's these urban structure let's
simply change all those and if we change
all those what will we get we will get
perfection we will have perfect
tyrannies so when you take the the
modernization theory that starts from
the idea that you're borrowing European
goods techniques personnel this and that
you're borrowing European in order to to
get to to European perfections democracy
Constitution this and that then then you
you you find that you you play out the
string to the end of the century and
none of it worked these places did not
become European liberal societies with
democratic and economically dynamic
cultures but if you take it from the
point of view of what I think is the the
other story that is to say the
undermining of the foundations a
religious Society you say what should be
the income what you should find is that
at the end of the story what you have is
is absolute Tyranny that worked that's
what we got that's we got in Turkey
under audit jerk in a fairly benign way
and after the World War two that's we
got in a whole series of military
dictatorships that have only now come
under threat so I think that the the
narrative that we are encouraged to file
though in the 1960s that have been
following ever since that said that the
purpose of borrowing from the West is to
become Western is it's not wrong but it
doesn't lead to the outcomes it only
leads to a sense that well I guess it
failed I guess something went wrong it
didn't happen but if you look at the
counter narrative which is that that
perhaps with European inspiration states
that were simultaneously taking other
steps that the Europeans weren't even
particularly aware of to undermine the
foundations of their own of their own
societies if in the to the extent that
those foundations were predicated on
long Islamic practices that worked from
the point of view rulers that came to
precisely the end that that the
theorists had predicted
if you remove Islamic law and the
independent guardians of Islamic law
from a position of influence in the
society because these scholars were
involved with the Sufi Brotherhood's
they're involved with the guilds are
involved every level of society if you
remove them what you should get is a
free track to become tyrannical so they
remove them and that's that's what they
got so in some respects what was
happening in Lee in the Islamic land I'm
empires in the ear of imperialism was a
profound transformation but it wasn't
the transformation that we wrote about
in this chapter now you'd think somebody
must have screwed up well
yeah I wrote the chapter or at least I
didn't I wouldn't be the first author of
the chapter I inherited the chapter from
another author and now I think it has to
be reconsidered the problem is that in
in world history I've talked before
about this issue of canonization if it
is assumed by all of the major
narratives that we have a world history
that the proper narrative is the one of
Europeanisation then what is the cost of
of going against that and coming up with
another counter narrative by the cost I
mean things like loss of market share
and diminution of my annual income so it
has to be done carefully
it has to be done with circumspection
but I think that we can come up I can
come up with a better story than the one
that we currently have in this chapter
on Thursday I'm going to talk somewhat
about the Chinese side of things and
probably not talk much about Russia but
you'll read about that in the chapter
you